what they're doing is a mass peaceful
protest in London thirty thousand two
hundred thousand people they've got two
main major demands certain assemblies
and most importantly their top demand is
the government should stop investing in
new fossil fuels the UN General
Secretary has said investment in new
fossil fuels is economic and moral
Madness so therefore what the what this
protest is doing is pulling the
emergency court and saying to the
government stop turbocharging North Sea
oil because it's actually a a
threatening the survival of humanity
okay so that's the message what about
the London marathon though on Sunday
because as we understand it the the race
organizer said he's received unique
assurances from uh Extinction Rebellion
that it won't be targeted that's what
you understand that's been a non-story
for for six to eight months they have
both agreed there would not be any
protests it's not an issue but what the
actual doing they're actually saying of
course the the London Marathon has many
people running it who support climate
action and who support the the aims of
the today's protests and which the
government to take action the idea that
the government is actually what is done
since in since sinek has become
Chancellor and prime minister it's
actually getting huge tax breaks to
North Sea oil and put a windfall tax on
Renewables and band we're the only
country in the world that's banned
onshore wind now that is surely criminal
Behavior okay and and the government
would no doubt if they were here defend
their record on those climate issues but
on the issue of a protest and what's
effective
um Lauren mckevitt do you welcome the
assurances from Extinction Rebellion
that they will leave the London Marathon
out of their protest this weekend
well I think it's probably one of the
more sensible things that they've done
because frankly what I think extension
Rebellion have ended up doing to
themselves and just stop oil are in the
the same category as this is they've
alienated a huge chunk of people within
middle England who actually
fundamentally agree with a lot of what
they're saying people who live in for
example rural communities who say well
you know what I have noticed the climate
changing my farming neighbor has changed
200-year planting schedules on the basis
of range changing so of course I
recognize that the climate has changed
but super gluing yourself to a Motorway
or bringing London to a standstill
neither of these are options that
actually win over heart and Minds to
your argument particularly when you
abuse statistics to the extent that
Extinction Rebellion do they often point
to the 8.5 RC RCP figure which is not a
forecast it is a model being used by
ipcc if nothing changes then indeed coal
consumption goes up so as long as
Extinction Rebellion are using shoddy
certificates and are blocking up hostile
routes in central London my own father
was blocked by 20 minutes going into a
diabetic coma going to a hospital by
Extinction rebellion in 2019 so I can't
stand these people because they put him
at risk and I think many people are in
the same camp as me what would you say
to that though well if the lady says she
is concerned about people in ambulances
absolutely right opposatory government's
record and ambulances hundreds of people
every month dying because of lack of
ambulance services so this is this is a
Canard the any protest will occupy a
street any protest will actually cause a
interruption in a city so the idea that
that's a can art what we need to focus
on is actually for example the 30
million people in Sudan facing death
from starvation and the 33 million
people in Pakistan suffering from from
flooding so that's where the real
concern should be sorry yeah the UK the
UK the UK's carbon emissions globally
are 0.93 at the end of 2021 as
percentage of overall carbon emissions
the cannot here is pointing to ambulance
times in the Tory government and not
extinct to Rebellion blocking ambulance
Roots I'm sorry a lot of account is also
going to Sudan and not the UK we only
have 30 seconds Lauren what does make
effective protests then just just
Marching In the Street peacefully the
politicians actually listened to that
very briefly
no they don't Lobby your members of
parliament bring them legitimate
statistics that you're concerned about
don't start falsifying ipcc's models
instead of actual legitimate forecasts
bring logic and reason to the table and
don't just you know participate in what
is extended performance art on the
Streets of London okay we are social to
time but Donna and Lauren we really
appreciate your time thanks both so much